die liebe ist für viele ein mysterium
aber dank der wissenschaft können wir
viel über die vorlieben und abneigungen
des jeweils anderen geschlechts erfahren
und ein wenig licht ins dunkel bringen
die besten tipps für staten gibt es
jetzt wirklich zum science fiction
der valentinstag ist gerade vorbei und
statistisch betrachtet musste über die
hälfte von euch den tag als single
verbringen aber keine angst passend dazu
dass ich mich gerade verliebt habe zwar
am dienstag möchte ich euch jetzt die
besten tipps der wissenschaft zum thema
liebe und dating geben denn kaum ein
anderes gebiet der menschlichen
interaktion wird so genau erforscht die
romantische beziehung zwischen zwei
menschen
bevor es aber losgeht noch ein kleiner
hinweis die tipps basieren auf
statistiken und durchschnittswerten
es kann also gut sein dass der ein oder
andere tipp auf euch oder eure partner
nicht zutrifft in köln sagen war jeder
jeck ist anders schreibt mir doch in die
kommentare
wenn er noch einen besseren tipps zum
thema ab ein trend hat sich in den
letzten jahren immer weiter etabliert
das online-dating wer keine ahnung hat
wo er suchen soll wird wohl am ehesten
im internet fündig über acht millionen
singles sind auf deutsch sprachigen
dating websites aktiv das wichtigste um
dann noch aufzufallen ist natürlich das
foto hier sollte genügend zeit
investiert werden denn das foto spielt
mit abstand die größte rolle bei der
entscheidung über ein erstes treffen
frauen stellen sich einer laut einer
studie am besten da wenn sie die kamera
über ihren kopf halten und so ein
bisschen schüchtern gucken und nein
bevor wir alle böse dinge schreiben die
wissenschafter haben dabei nur fotos
genommen auf denen kein ausschnitt zu
sehen war und trotzdem wurde diese art
von fotos am häufigsten von männern
kontaktiert männer sollten nicht direkt
in die kamera gucken also wie ich es
gemacht habe und ein bisschen
spektakulärer solchen aussehen und laut
einer studie hat sich ergeben dass ich
manche frauen von einem direkten blick
nämlich eingeschüchtert fühlen konnten
solltet ihr euer profil dann mit ein
paar humorvollen setzen über euch und
ein wenig darüber welche eigenschaften
euch in einem partner wichtig sind das
optimale verhältnis ist hier bei 70 zu
zwei bis drei wochen nach dem ersten
kontakt ist laut der wissenschaft der
optimale zeitpunkt für das erste date
hier kann sich eine gute vorbereitung
bezahlt machen wir zum beispiel rote
kleidung anzieht wird wesentlich
häufiger auch ein zweites und drittes
state bekommen da die warme farbe mit
einer wärmeren persönlichkeit verbunden
wird frauen verstehen unter dieser
warmen persönlichkeit meistens romantik
männer erotik den gleichen effekt gibt
es bei der temperatur bei der richtigen
temperatur eine warme tasse in der hand
assoziiert euer gehirn mit besseren
charaktereigenschaften beim gegenüber
genauso wichtig wie das aussehen sind
natürlich auch noch dinge wie geruch
mundgeruch geht mal garnicht und wird
von beiden geschlechtern als grund
nummer eins für ein schlechtes date
angegeben und männer zu beruhigen nur
sieben prozent der frauen kümmern sich
darum was der mann eigentlich sagt viel
wichtiger ist seine körpersprache und
selbstbewusstsein und sogar wie jemand
etwas sagt ist mit knapp 40 prozent
immer noch wesentlich wichtiger als das
was gesagt wird
frauen können durch ein lachen hie und
da viel gewinnen wären männer auch mit
der stimme selbstbewusstsein
signalisieren sollten
das bringt uns perfekt zum nächsten
punkt welche eigenschaften sind während
des denkens am wichtigsten wie schon
erwähnt suchen frauen besonders
selbstbewusste männer fast genauso
wichtig ist aber ein verständnisvoller
zuhörer
männer hingegen geben an eine aufregende
persönlichkeit und intelligenz in der
partnerin zu suchen beide geschlechter
finden laut der studie das aussehen eher
zweitrangig so lange es kein ko
kriterium wie ein sichtbar fehlenden
zahn gibt oder etwas anderes ist also
wichtig nicht einfach nur nett zu sein
sondern auch etwas spannendes und
aufregendes zu bieten und wer sich das
nicht einfach aus dem ärmel schütteln
kann der bekommt jetzt einen super job
gleich mehrere studien haben nämlich
festgestellt wie wichtig der ort und die
aktivität eines ersten dates sein können
am besten sind nämlich aufregende
aktivitäten die den adrenalinspiegel in
die höhe schießen lassen
das führt dazu dass sich das gegenüber
besser an euch erinnert und euch mit dem
adrenalin in verbindung bringt optimal
sind achterbahnfahrten auf der kirmes
oder höher gelegene punkt punkte mit
aussicht im gegensatz dazu kann ein
schlechter kinofilm das gegenteil
bewirken
dann erinnert man sich gleichzeitig mit
der person an auch an die langeweile
hinzu kommt noch dass man im kino nicht
miteinander spricht und sich so gar
nicht mehr kennenlernen kann wenn es
aber unbedingt kino sein muss dann ist
ein horrorfilm optimal das adrenalin im
körper intensiviert euer date ungemein
wenn er mitnimmt date keine ahnung habe
ob er oder sie euch interessant findet
oder über schreiend weglaufen würde
hilft eine vorsichtige annäherung wenn
man zum beispiel nebeneinander läuft
kann man versuchen sich dem anderen ein
wenig zu nähern
wenn euer date ausweicht und denselben
abstand wie vorher einem tja das ist
dann nicht so toll aber wenn der
annäherungsversuch zugelassen oder sogar
erwidert wird wisst ihr dass euch die
zuneigung der anderen person gewiss ist
wenn am ende alle tipps befolgt habt und
ihr männer euch nach dem dritten bzw
frauen euch nach dem durchschnitt 14
treffen verliebt habt so wenn die daten
aus dann sollte euch eins bewusstsein
verliebte menschen sind auf droge in
ernster gehören sieht aus in dieser
rosaroten phase wie das gehirn eines
computers dopamin und noradrenalin
strömen durch euren körper und ihr könnt
nicht mehr klar denken
wer verliebt ist ist hey wer durch eine
trennung geht muss auch ähnliches
durchmachen wie wichtige bei einem
entzug mehr zum thema drogen übrigens
der vater in diesem video alkohol mit
selbstversuch und mehr infos zum thema
gibt es kokos und zwar was er nicht mit
eurem schwamm tun solltet dafür
hier klicken
und wie immer unten in der video
beschreibung gibt es mehr infos und was
meint er
was ist euch in der liebe wichtig um was
geht beim ersten date mal so gar nicht
schreibt es uns in den kommentaren
bis dann